what's up guys my name is not Forrest
but this ugly car behind me is the most
tech I have ever seen in a car so this
is BMW's full-size fully electric i7 it
is longer than a Cadillac Escalade so
it's got a lot of room for Tech inside
despite looking kind of like a squinting
Pig so inside there are screens powered
by Wireless Android auto and carplay
there's sensors up here so you can do
this to change the volume there's also a
wireless charger here there's speakers
everywhere including in the doors
there's a headrest one and there's
woofers in the seat so you can feel the
base but also the driving sounds are
composed by Hans Zimmer
but what you really want to be is
definitely this back seat so of course
you've got a wireless charger here in
front of some hidden cup holders there's
a hidden USB C Port but there are
screens in each of the doors where I can
change modes and if I hit theater mode
it puts up all the shades including the
back and the roof and drops down a 30
inch 8K touch screen so I can watch
videos you know strategically placed
microphones all around the car hey BMW
open my shade it just opens mine and
none of the others also subscribe to
Forex Who does these way better than me